looking forward to that folks and we
witness combos fatalities but one of the
hallmarks that mortal comet has always
been the rich detailed stories so what
can we look forward to an immortal comet
11 when it comes to the story yeah you
saw a glimpse of the beginning of the
story here we actually have a video here
it's the entire opening cinematic the
whole prologue of the story it really
picks up right after MK 9 and I think
you guys are going to get a big kick out
of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please Cyprus you know
[Music]
but you wear my amulets finally you
embrace the truth the elder gods deny
the truth I was cast out for speaking
the truth I embraced shinnok is that
mercy is wasted on those who defile her
throne I will destroy our enemies before
they destroy us
starting with you not even you can kill
an elder God
there are fates worse than death
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Biron deliver you to reclaim your
NetherRealm engines you'll serve as
warning and an emblem of my
[Music]
[Music]
this is what your destination aapke once
again the thunder god has upset the
balance of history no this the arc of
universe bends to my will
[Music]
it is only a matter of time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
edie that was amazing April 23rd cannot
come soon enough
so the story picks off right after MKX
dark rain rains time is being
manipulated how fun was it to dive into
the rich mortal kombat lore and design
moments when these legendary characters
confront a different version of
themselves yeah that was the most fun
about you know how we created the story
we basically introduce a character
chronica who has been kind of running
the show since the first mortal kombat
everything that was happening was it to
her plan up to the point where Raiden
kind of screwed things up and that's
when she's kind of stepping in and she's
just going to play tricks with time
that's going to introduce situations
where old characters meeting their
younger selves and it's it's it's such a
great great story mode we could not be
more proud of this Ed Boon thank you so
much for being here give it up for the
legend maybe some gentleman now